and that's why I think Scientology is
right not just for this city but for the
country I really hi welcome back
um
sorry moving the show along our next
presenters are two very talented
brothers which I realized is also an
excellent way to describe the Baldwin
family
please welcome Luke and Owen Wilson
we're very honored to present live
action short because our first project
together was a 13 minute short called
bottle rocket we're incredibly thank you
we're incredibly proud of the fact that
later on we got five million to expand
it into a feature film that grossed
almost 1 million dollars and that was 1
million back in 1996 before inflation
and now the nominees for live action
short house ricer the runaway or wreak a
rota cash back Sean Ellis and Lena bow
singer the last farm runner Arun ursin
and Thor SC göransson our time is up
Rob Pearlstein and Pia Clemente
six-shooter Martin McDonagh
and the Oscar goes to six-shooter Martin
McDonagh
this is the first Academy Award
nomination for Martin McDonagh
hi I just like to thank everybody who
was involved in the film especially
Brendan Gleeson and Rory Conroy and Rory
I'm sorry that you couldn't be here
tonight but I hope next time if they let
you into the country I'd like to say hi
to my mom and dad back in Ireland and a
big hello to everyone involved in the
lieutenant of Inishmore at the Atlantic
in New York thanks
and now please welcome two of the
biggest stars of the past year Chicken
Little and Abby Mallard
hello and good evening have you ever
seen a more fashionable crowd I thought
this was black-tie optional boy do I
feel underdressed yeah it isn't really
splurged on my wardrobe seriously mr.
Uyghur what is up with Doc's and no
meals Ricky gets pants
goofy gets pants even the wooden puppet
kid gets later hosing but the docks they
never get the pants I mean really I
wasn't gonna make any political speeches
but I won't wear pants until there is
pants equality for all wow I'm really
touched
I mean the whole works watching
and the nominees are badgered Sharon
Coleman the moon on the Sun an imagined
conversation John Kane maker and Peggy
stern the mysterious Geographic
explorations of Jasper Morello Anthony
Lucas nine Shane Acker one-man band
Andrew Jimenez and Mark Andrews and the
Oscar goes to the moon in the Sun an
imagined conversation John Kay maker and
Peggy stone
this is the first Academy Award
nomination for John King maker and Peggy
Stewart
Peggy and I thank the Academy for this
great honor and also for your faith in
the hand-drawn animation which still can
pack an emotional wallop I want to thank
my brother and sister Tony and Kathleen
Kennesaw Oh my talented life partner
Joseph Kennedy Sheila Nevins and Jacki
Glover at HBO
Ron set-offs music David melman's
wonderful editing and all my students
and colleagues at NYU Tisch School of
the Arts peg thank you to Eli Wallach
and John Turturro for your sensitive
vocal performances thank you to my
brother Tom Stern my husband Alan Ruskin
and for those of you who are moms and
juggle working in this business you'll
understand my tremendous thank you to my
children Ben and Emma and my mom Joanne
Stern okay